okay he said it was forty percent okay
he had some grace but he didn't try to
yeah a little harder okay
look how big mario was too mario
that was good though he got him there
that night now watch mario goes to the
couch
[Music]
by the way when we asked everyone who
they'd rather get hit everyone chose
mario but uh unfortunately we got paul
here so no no paul come on up here paul
line it up let's let uh rashad put the
gloves on nice let's see how this is
gonna be somebody stand behind paul and
case the uh the apollo creed special
here
all right here we go
if a tooth falls out it's there you go
hang on can we get one still rashad
evan's in the house hey come on come on
ufc hall of famer about to knock out
paul
can we get a weigh-in picture here
it's okay buddy
david ready ready
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he said thank you
hey hug it out guys it's over
seven eight
nine ten
we're out all right so paul we need
commentary tell us the difference
chuckle adele rashad evans
okay here we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
i mean one of the good news is those are
the 16 so when chuck hit us it was a
smaller glove too
but
yeah you're feeling it though
hey paul the good news you got the day
off buddy yeah
i'm sorry man well you're amazing
we appreciate the bravery these gloves
you can kind of feel the knuckle coming
through a little bit
hang on here these are the tyson fury
models man somebody uh somebody get
rashad a sharpie we gotta get that
signed
wow
tell me you're joking okay good because
he was going to do it to you if you
weren't rolling not the ball oh we
didn't have it
paul would you like tickets to lose dude
his eyes are glossed over it's not this
is no bs your eyes are you talking about
why don't we get policy first of all
well lunch is on us yeah why don't we
get police you're probably one of the
only people i know that's been punched
by two hall of famers ufc hall of famers
so you ought to be proud of yourself but
to not get paid for any by the way
how do you feel right now about you know
i feel bad man i feel bad about it i
don't feel bad you all right though
look at the big grin what was it like
getting punched like uh by liddell in
the ring is he the hardest puncher you
ever faced he's one of them man chuck
chuck clicked me with a couple shots and
uh
it was like
it felt all the way down to my toes man
you felt it all the way down to your
toes oh wow
like like just shocked you're nervous
like an electric shock interesting wow
that's like the next the next level
stuff because you've been punched a lot
and then somebody that's what that's
what happens before you get knocked out
before you get knocked out like you get
hit and then your feet like you feel it
down to your feet and then you can't
feel your legs anymore and you see
people start getting a stanky leg it's
because they can't feel their feet like
you never heard a tournament this
terminology well rampage term that that
he that's what he said to me after i got
knocked out by the machida so
but uh yeah so when you it goes to your
legs and then you can't feel your legs
anymore so that's why the legs start
getting funny and then you go down so if
liddell's not the hardest you've been
hit though huh
i would say keith jardine was the
hardest idea he's jordan jardine hits
like a mack truck man really yeah what a
name from the past keith jardine holy
the dean of maine yeah this might be a
good segue to talk about who you're
gonna knock out this weekend or this
coming up uh fight in what less than ten
days yep i'm fighting uh gabriel checko
from vegas uh mostly grappler but he's
got some hands he's he can you know he
can uh he can throw some punches big
bigger guys and that's january 28th in
miami miami do you know where the fight
is exactly the location it's going to be
at the um
the old nickelodeon uh building they
bought that out and they've done a
phenomenal job of making it like the
apec center
and uh it's uh it's habib did an amazing
job like in the whole production team
they did an amazing job with this
facility is he representing you are you
with him now with his camp now or i'm
well i'm with ali abdelaziz and we're
you know we're stable mates with ali but
uh it's um
the eagle promotions
and i mean you know habib they spared no
expense with this place it's a state of
the yard is really props to him good for
him you think he's coming back or no you
think he's ever gonna
nah i think man i seen habibi but b was
probably like 210 pounds no no he's a
big dude but not in a bad way he's just
like oh not like the prince in that same
way no no he's he's got he's he's he's
big
he's big though he's just
wide back just look like he's just been
eating and just doing it i've always
heard that about anderson silva man when
guys i trained with like edson barbosa
and those guys and dante rivera they'd
say like silver walks around like 225
and cuts down into the 180s like the
dude yeah he's a he's a big dude too
yeah
amazing sharpie
homeboy sharpie what should we expect
for the fight you said he's a grappler
but you're a grappler too i guess diego
silva you know you showed the world that
you could grapple yeah and you pulled
that out of the bag and in the strategy
for that fight what does what should we
expect for this fight
um
i don't know you know the truth of the
matter is that you know he he's a
grappler so i'm sure he's probably gonna
try to get me down to the ground
be on top and try to work at submission
games uh
but he knows that i'm a wrestler too as
well
so you know he's gonna be willing to
exchange with me uh probably tried to
catch me with some punches but um
i don't know man it's just you know it's
hard to say what's going to happen in
the fight situation especially since
i've been out for so long and you know
this was the last time
was it 2018
dude this is
43 for almost four years yeah
wow are you excited are you nervous how
you i mean you've been fought four years
almost yeah i'm i'm excited i'm nervous
i'm all those things i'm uh i have a
wave of roller coaster emotions but you
know this is this is why i wanted to do
it you know to be able to feel this
feeling again i mean there's nothing
like
the feeling of a fight because you know
you're not so much fighting an opponent
you're fighting yourself you know and
that's where that's where the true
challenge is is really
fighting yourself to you know bring
yourself mentally there in order to be
able to bring yourself physically there
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]